the moment that I first saw you I knew
that we could have something that could
last a long time what is this a real
proposal I've been saving this date for
you Becca will you marry sorry that's
all ABC would let us see in this
exclusive clip but is it a trick because
what we shot in Vegas was behind the
scenes of Ben and Becca's first
one-on-one date they actually perform a
ceremony for another couple I'm actually
ordained and I'm well I have the ability
to marry some people so today I've
invited Becca
to join me at the little white wedding
chapel and we're actually gonna be
marrying some couples who have agreed to
let me do that worst case scenario is
that they we ruin the best day of their
life do you Travis choose to marry Leah
so how does Becca feel about all of this
coming into the day I had no idea what
we could be doing I mean I assumed that
we probably wouldn't really get married
but I never guessed this so I love being
surprised so this is actually really fun
for me I now pronounce you husband and
wife you may now kiss the bride
while this couple walks off and what
seems like wedded bliss would Ben
himself ever have a Vegas quickie
wedding I'm all about this I think just
getting married is really exciting thing
and it's you know however the certain
couple ones to do it is fine but for me
it might be a little bigger